hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 23 hört zu und spricht nach
hast du ein haustier hast du ein
haustier
ja ich habe eine katze ja ich habe eine
katze ja ich habe einen hund ja ich habe
einen hund
nein ich habe kein haustier
nein ich habe kein haustier wie alt bist
du
wie alt bist du
ich bin 29 jahre alt ich bin 29 jahre
alt ich bin älter als du ich bin älter
als du ich bin schon 35 jahre alt ich
bin schon 35 jahre alt ich esse gerne
hoffen ich esse gern kartoffeln
ich esse lieber reis ich esse lieber
reis ich esse am liebsten teigwaren
ich esse am liebsten teigwaren ich
trinke gern t
ich trinke gern t
ich trinke lieber kaffee
ich trinke am liebsten bier
ich trinke am liebsten bier eine orange
enthält viel vitamin c
eine orange enthält viel vitamin c
eine
sie enthält mehr vitamin c eine kiwi
enthält mehr vitamin c eine rote
peperoni enthält am meisten vitamin c
eine rote peperoni enthält am meisten
vitamin c die rote jacke gefällt mir gut
die rote jacke gefällt mir gut
die blaue jacke gefällt mir besser
die
zur jacke gefällt mir am besten die
schwarze jacke gefällt mir am besten
das gelbe kleid ist schön das gelbe
kleid ist schön
ich finde das rote kleid schöner
ich finde das rote kleid schöner das
grüne kleid ist meiner meinung nach am
schönsten
das grüne kleid ist meiner meinung nach
am schönsten
wie schwer bist du wie schwer bist du
ich bin 65 kilo schwer
ich bin leichter als du
ich bin 55 kilo schwer
ich bin leichter als du ich bin 55 kilo
schwer
ich bin
jeder als du ich bin 78 kilo schwer
ich bin schwerer als du ich bin 78 kilo
schwer
wie groß bist du wie groß bist du ich
bin einen meter 75 groß
ich bin einen meter 75 groß
ich bin größer als du ich bin einen
meter 82 groß ich bin größer als du ich
bin einen meter 82 groß ich bin kleiner
als du
ich bin einen meter 73 crews ich bin
kleiner als du
ich bin einen meter 73 groß
schöner am schönsten schön schön am
schönsten lustig lustiger am lustigsten
lustig lustiger am lustigsten heiß
heißer am heißesten
heiß heißer am heißesten
kalt kälter am kältesten
kalt kälter am kältesten günstig
günstiger am günstigsten sind
günstiger am günstigsten laut lauter am
lautesten laut lauter am lautesten
groß größer am größten
groß größer am größten alt älter
am ältesten alt älter am ältesten teuer
teurer
am teuersten teuer teurer
am teuersten vielmehr am meisten
vielmehr am meisten gut besser am besten
gut besser am besten
[Musik]